president Trump sparring with the media
over his comments on slowing down
coronavirus testing
take a look I don't kid let me just tell
you let me make it clear we have got the
greatest testing program anywhere in the
world we test better than anybody in the
world our tests are the best in the
world and we have the most of them by
having more tests
we find more cases we did 25 plus 25
million tests and dr. Anthony foul she
was up on Capitol Hill today for a
hearing on kovat 19 he was asked if
President Trump has told task force
members to decrease testing watch this I
is a member of the task force and my
colleagues on the task force to my
knowledge I know for sure but to my
knowledge none of us have ever been told
to slow down on testing that just is a
fact in fact we will be doing more
testing Jessie I just thought you know
let's look at the timeline here you have
the president make a statement out in
Tulsa then you have the campaign he said
he he makes them then the campaign the
issues a statement says he was joking
then the president comes back and says
he wasn't joking that the media and the
Democrats tell him to make that
statement that they tell the campaign to
make this thing what's going on here
Jessie no I don't know I think when the
president says that I told them to stop
doing testing that's going to be in a
Joe Biden ad in the fall and the
president's going to regret saying that
but I mean obviously we're doing more
testing more testing than any other
country all of them combined and you
understand the president's point is that
when you do more testing you get more
cases over 99% of those cases the people
fully recover and the media has prepared
us that there was going to be new cases
we all expected that but the way that
the media frames new cases now seems to
indicate that we should all stay lock
down and the president screwed up and
that's just not fair because it feels
like politics when they repeat the
phrase new cases new cases new case
two weeks after there was millions of
people in the streets all over the
country
it just seems suspicious and like we
started out with the phrase that they
repeated over and over again cases then
there was the word deaths over and over
then there was ventilators over and over
and and then now we're at new cases and
spike and I predict in the fall the
phrase of the day they're gonna hear all
the time is going to be second wave and
that's just how they play it
all right so Greg we in fact if you look
at the numbers the president said this
we are now per capita about on testing
where much of the world is Europe but in
Europe they're having a decline in cases
we're having an increase what's going on
here what's the what's the difference
all the differences people aren't
telling the story it doesn't the
increase in cases okay
happens there are a couple of variables
number one they're not actually
separating the cases that have already
cleared up or healed so they keep
accumulating so if somebody says what
they're now at 150,000 cases they're at
you know it's it's natural that that
would be more than the month before
number two why isn't anybody talking
about the death rate why isn't anybody
talking about the hospitalization rate
instead they're talking about more cases
it's kind of interesting to me because
when you have more cases which is what
you're seeing with the testing because
when you have the testing you find more
cases you're gonna see the death rate go
down the good news is because because
obviously it's a percentage of the cases
that of people being alive it's gonna go
down the debts but nobody's actually
telling you what the death rate is also
it's it's just weird and but the good
news is hospitalizations are declining
so the case thing is not important it's
hospitalization and deaths and I don't
know why we don't lead with that
information that would be pretty
interesting well actually you're right I
mean I think hospitalizations are down
but again no one wants to get sick and
be in that possible position so Dana
when you hear all of these comments from
the president about it I
think you it invites people to think
this is political like do you wear a
mask or not wear a mask does that mean
you're a trump supporter or not is the
president here politicizing what should
be just the public health discussion I
wish that the mask thing had not become
political and I don't necessarily think
it's the president alone that is
suggesting that I do think that if we
all want the economy to get back and get
back more quickly that an acceptance of
masks should be something that we are
willing to consider and if you don't
want to wear one if you don't want to go
out like that's okay too
hopefully you'll buy some things online
but we've got to get this economy moving
and mass could be one way I do want to
comment on the communications angle
though when the president said on
Saturday night so I asked my team slow
down on testing and I immediately
thought that was that it was a joke that
was funny and so it wasn't surprising to
me that the campaign and then the next
day the White House press secretary from
the White House podium says obviously
the president was joking and I thought
they put that in a nice little box and
the ad that Jesse suggested that the
Biden campaign would run everybody would
roll their eyes at like obviously the
president was joking but now he's not
joking that he wasn't joking and that
the testing is better and that we're
doing more testing the joke was that he
would had told his team to slow down on
the testing so that his numbers would
look better and I don't understand why
he felt the need to re rub that spot on
the wall and I've paid a price for I
think 14 years now for telling a joke
that was clearly very funny to me but it
didn't come across funny and I didn't
have anybody defending me telling me
that saying that it was a joke and for a
while it happened on NPR and I've
regretted it ever since so if when he's
gonna go forward and have these campaign
rallies and he's gonna riff he just has
to think about that a little bit before
so that he could signal when he's
actually joking and then if his team
cleans something up let it sit that was
really interesting but I so Katie what
I'm not sure what to make of that he
he's the one that said I wasn't joking
so Dana can't get it I can't get it so
we turn to Katie Pavlich
well I think this is one of those
situations where you have to look at the
results rather than what the President
did or did not say whether he was
serious or whether he was joking or not
a month ago the complaint was that we
have too much testing that there are not
enough people to take this test and now
when the president says this I also
thought he was joking that he's going to
he's told this team to do fewer tests it
has become an outrage after they cleaned
it up because he then says he was not
joking but the facts on the ground show
that the federal government has followed
through with our obligation to get the
hospital's ready and to get the states
the testing they need through those
private public partnerships with with
got businesses like CVS and Walgreens so
if you take a look around at the way
testing is going in most places where
we're seeing more of these these cases
come up in these cases be discovered I
think you can say that the results speak
for themselves
even if the joke did not go over well
thanks Katie